it was ancient pageantry viewed through
a 21st century lens
[Music]
ritual that was last seen 70 years ago
then marking the start
and now the end of the second
elizabethan age
with one voice and consent of tongue and
heart
publish and proclaim
that the prince charles philip arthur
george
is now
by the death of our late sovereign of
happy memory
become our only lawful and rightful
liege lord
charles iii
for the first time cameras were allowed
inside as politicians past and present
of all political persuasions gathered
inside st james's palace
the privy council at first assembling
without the new king but with his wife
and son among them as privy councillors
to acknowledge formally the change of
reign
by the grace of god of the united
kingdom of great britain and northern
ireland
and of his other realms and territories
king
head of the commonwealth
defender of the faith
god save the king
moved into the throne room they were
finally joined by king charles
his heir and queen consort close by
as we were all able to witness a moment
never seen before
a monarch holding his first privy
council meeting
personally declaring his
intention to serve
my lords ladies and gentlemen
it is my most sorrowful duty
to announce to you the death of my
beloved mother the queen
i know how deeply you
the entire nation
and i think i may say the whole world
sympathize with me
in the irreparable loss we've all
suffered
my mother's reign was unequaled
in its duration
its dedication and its devotion
even as we grieve
we give thanks
for this most faithful life
i am deeply aware
of this great inheritance
and of the duties and heavy
responsibilities
of sovereignty
which have now passed to me
in taking up these responsibilities
i shall strive to follow
the inspiring example
i have been set
and in carrying out the heavy task that
has been laid upon me
and to which i now dedicate what remains
to me
of my life
i pray
for the guidance and help
of almighty god
it's the personal touches his family
around him the inkwell on the table
given him as a gift by prince william
and prince harry
a reminder this is a time of mourning
a solemn occasion for all involved
members of the new cabinet and the
current prime minister and
representatives from the commonwealth it
was poignant because people were
recognizing how much
her majesty the queen had given us but
also
welcoming the new king
and for the new king charles to make
those constitutional
declarations in such a sober and
profound way i think was moving for
everyone and it is a moment i'm sure no
one in that room will ever forget
the ceremony in essence is one of
welcome and fanfare the crowds quickly
adapting to a new national anthem
and going further in their appreciation
three cheers for his majesty the king
hip hip
hip hip
hip hip
echoed in the city of london as the
second proclamation was read on the
steps of the royal exchange
god save the king
in the coming days it will be repeated
across the united kingdom
for now buckingham palace remains the
focal point at times people being turned
away because the crowds were too deep
barriers now in place all along the mall
but behind them a king who wants to be
seen
who wants us to understand what we're
now witnessing as like us he's quickly
had to adjust
rhiannon mills sky news at st james's
palace